this is Startalk uh Alex
hers dawn nope nope herds on Alex herds
on whatever all right Alex herds on
wants to know this and says this hello
dr. Tyson is there any time dilation dr.
Neil to him is there any time dilation
on Mars and if so could it affect the
age of people living there in comparison
to the people on earth alright oh so you
can get time dilation this is from
relativity where we learn there are two
things that can make you live more
slowly than others that's called time
dilation oh one of them is if you're
moving fast relative to people looking
at you the other is yogurt so yoga
actually doesn't slow you down it just
makes you live longer if the ads are
correct correct right but the real
question comes down to how long does the
passage of one second take as observed
by others who see you right so if you're
moving fast through space your time will
tick more slowly as observed by others
and we know this from Einstein it works
we duplicate this in particle
accelerators that's not even a question
right all right now gravity high level
gravity also slows down your time this
was a major element of the movie but
portrayed in the plotline of the movie
interstellar so Earth's surface has a
higher gravity than Martian surface so
on Mars you will live your seconds
faster slightly faster lightly
deliberate living here on earth that's
right and so oh by the way just to give
you a sense of how strong is if this
effect can accumulate our Geel our gps
satellites are orbiting like five
hundred miles up they are farther away
from Earth's surface from Earth's center
than we are ok farther away ok they're
in a reduced gravity relative to us
which means their clocks tick faster
than ours yet GPS has given you the
correct time
we pre correct GPS satellites for
Einstein's general theory of relativity
so that when it sends the time back to
earth it has the correct time oh my I
have such a new appreciation from my
phone because all I do is click it on to
find out what time it is and it's never
wrong I didn't know that much trouble
went in to finding out that it's 4:15 or
10:30 exact well exactly so yeah so it's
not a big effect and if you go to Mars
this isn't you shouldn't be distracted
by this fact there's where a black hole
yeah you'd have to you do your
calculation before you went right right
right cool all right there you go man
it was a black hole you went to it uh
one year for you it could be a hundred
years on earth and and you come back and
everyone would have forgotten about you
yeah but the problem is how do you come
back from a black hole yeah no you're
right
right now yeah it's it so forget it
that's one waitress Chuck caught me on
that one or and I've been hanging out
with too long I know man hey this is
Startalk